Hi, guys. Good morning.
My name is Dr.
Patel. I'm one of the
pediatricians, and
today I'm going to
be presenting on
pediatric immunology.
This is just
my information.
I live in Sororio 123,
which is on the
first floor,
and then this is
my email address
if you have
any questions.
All right, let's
get started. So the
objectives of this lecture
is recognizing some
basic concepts of pediatric
immunodeficiencies
and then also
some of the common
immune deficiencies.
So those are divided
into sections of which
part is affected.
So we're going to
talk about fangocyte
disorders, combined T
and B cell disorder, T
cell disorder, B cell
disorder, and then
these categories of
other which sort of
combine some multiple
systems and the
specific pathologies
that we're going to talk
about are leukocyte
adhesion deficiency,
SCID or severe combined
immunodeficiency,
DeJorge syndrome,
Bruton X-linked A
-gamma globinemia,
hyper IgM and
then Jobe syndrome
which is hyper IgE.
We're also going to
talk about Wiscott
-Eldrich syndrome
and then ataxia
tolexandria. Okay.
And these are the
acronyms that I will
probably be using
throughout the slides.
All right. So we're
going to start with
the starter question
to make it fun.
And I know you guys
get Dr. Hurst's lecture
as well prior to this,
which helps you kind
of recognize
immunodeficiencies. So I won't
spend too much time on
this, but I do think
it's important to kind
of go through. So in
your exams, when you
get a question, you'll
have to kind of think
to yourself okay what
are the important
components of the question
that they want me to
take away from this to
get my answer so even
before you look at
your answer choices I
want you guys to in your
head go through and
highlight the things
that you think are
important to know from this
question stem so for
example our question
is a two-month-old infant
is brought into your
office with a recent
hospital admission
for two weeks for
pneumocystis pneumonia or
*** requiring respiratory
support and in
reviewing the chart the
infant had had multiple
episodes of thrush
that required prolonged
antifungal treatment.
The growth chart shows
that the infant's head
circumference weight
and length have been
below the 1.5 percentile.
On exam he has severe
seborrheic dermatitis
and a bulging right
TM to panic membrane.
You've reviewed the x
-ray from the hospital,
the just x-ray, and
they comment on an
absent thymic shadow.
The flow cytometry
shows decreased B,
T, and NK cells and
decreased immunoglobulins.
So what is the most
likely mechanism causing
this presentation?
Okay, and most of the
time as you get in
higher level questions,
they will ask you
second-order, third
-order questions. So
they'll ask you something
like, what is the
side effect of the drug
that you will treat
with? So that requires
you to know, A,
what the diagnosis may
be, B, what the treatment
would be, and then
C, the side effect
of it, right? So third
-order questions is
what you're working
towards for step two.
But step one is going
to be a little bit
more basic, asking you
about more pathophys,
more diagnoses, and
things like that.
So that's good. So
in this question's
time, the things that
I think are important
to highlight for you
guys are the age.
So the age will always
help you determine
what pathology is
most common in this
age range, which is
exactly what they're
asking you for when
they ask you that
in a question. So age
is super important.
The patient recently
had *** pneumonia, so
pneumocystis, which is
an uncommon pneumonia
to have, especially as
an infant, right? uh
and then they've had
multiple episodes of
thrush so remember
thrush is candida okay so
they've had uh candida
in their mouth um that
required prolonged anti
-treatment antifungal
treatment right a
little bit thrush that
goes away with some
niastatin um which is the
antifungal that you
treat with is okay fine
but this baby has had
multiple episodes and
has required prolonged
treatment, okay? Then
it also tells you from
the growth chart that
this baby has failure
to grow, right? So it
has trouble gaining
weight in all aspects.
And then they have
some severe skin
findings of
dermatitis and then a
right bulging TM
which shows you
otitis media in a
two-month-old, okay?
On the x-ray you find
that there's absent
thymic shadow which
is also important for
immunology purposes and
then the flow cytometry
will tell you exactly
which cells are affected
okay all right so I
want you guys to keep
that keep these
highlighted points in mind
while we go through
this uh powerpoint okay
all right so let's
quickly talk about just
some basics um I like
pictures a lot because
I'm a very picture
person so I hope this
relates to you um so I
like to think of innate
immunity as sort of your
if there's something
going on there's a
murder or a robbery
the first people on the
scene are usually the
policemen right or
women so um you'll find
all these cells are
sort of the first call
in who comes to the
site of infection or or
problem so you have mast
cells um eosinophils
granulocytes neutrophils
um uh you get nk
cells you get some of
the phagocytic system
so monocytes and just
dendritic cells which
are your APCs so antigen
presenting cells so
they present the antigen
to the t-cell and
was like here look
this is the problem um
macrophages which
will kind of just eat
everything up and then
of course complement is
also in this innate system
right so a complement
um is your is your c
your all your proteins
and And then C2, 3,
and then all the way
from 5 to 9 form that
MAC complex, which then
help degrade bacteria,
right? So complement
and all these granulocytes
are part of the
innate system, which
are your first kind
of responders, okay?
Then you have adaptive.
So adaptive will be
your longer, slower
process bones of
players. And so
this is sort of your
FBI, right? Right.
So they have more memory.
They're able to do
more directed therapies
and they have a lot
more resources. Right.
So I think about it
like that in my head.
So for humoral, I think
about B cells and
kind of expanding out
their antibodies, like
go catch them kind of
thing. And then I have
cellular. So cellular
will be sort of the
head chief person,
director, if you may, and
they will differentiate
into CD4 and CD8
cells, which are your
helper cells and your
killer cells. Right. So,
again, these all help
in, you know, they're
all interconnected. So
T cells will activate
B cells and antigen
presenting cells will
present to T cells.
So you have all this
interconnectivity. And
then, of course, you have
the NK cells and the
T cells are sort of
in between these two
because they can kill by
themselves or cytotoxic
stuff. But they
also sometimes will
activate other cells or
like create memory and
stuff. So those are sort
of how you want to
think about these two.
You can also, I
guess, think about it
like in terms of EMS
being your innate
system and then
adaptive being your
hospital system, your
emergency medicine
doc who will then
have more experience
and more resources
to kind of help
directed therapy to
help your patient.
OK, and then I want
to just quickly
go over T-cell
dependent versus
T-cell independent
activation.
So as you can see, T
-cell independent, you
just have a B-cell with,
and you can tell it's
a B-cell because it has
all these antibodies
on it, and it attaches
directly to the
pathogenic parts of the
bacteria, which the B
-cell recognizes as
abnormal, and then it will
expand and cause plasma
cells, so maturation,
and then that will
produce more IgM, which
will then be directed
at this specific
bacteria. so this is
one way the other way is
using T cells to help
so you have another B
cell here and they're
going to now present this
antigen they were
gonna they're gonna be
the antigen presenting
cell and that will go
to the T cell and be
like hey look this is
this is something I
found that seems abnormal
what should I do and
so the T cell will be
like oh we need to
attack these these are
abnormal so there are
some cytokines or chemical
kind of communication
methods to the b cell
which then will activate
it which then will
create more plasma
cells with specific
antibodies so these are
smaller right so these
are probably igg as
you can tell these are
igms so you have some
restriction on where
they can travel and what
they can kill and then
you form also memory
b cells so that will
also cause more of these
compounds to be able
to be recognized by
the B cell. So the T
cell-dependent activation
is a much stronger,
more long-lived
immunoresponse
versus the independent
one, which causes
a more short,
robust response.
And then this is also
the direct kind of
picture of antibody
-mediated toxicity.
So once an antibody
will attach the antigen,
then the NK cell,
which is a granulocyte,
can come over,
recognize the antibody
and they'll be like,
oh, I have to kill
this. So then we'll
release a bunch of
granulocytes, granulocytes
and perforins,
which will cause
little holes in the,
in the cell causing
apoptosis, right? So,
okay, general
overview, you guys know
this stuff, but I just
like pictures. So,
all right. So for
immunodeficiencies, remember
what I said, age is
really important. So
at what age do they
present with symptoms
of frequent infections?
It will help you
determine what pathology
it is. So as you can
see, the severe combined
immune deficiency or
SCID and DeGeorge and
the leukocyte adhesion
defects, those show
up very early on,
right? So in the first
couple months of life.
And then you get the
antibody deficiencies
after six months to
about two years. And I
want you guys to think
about why, right? So
remember, mom's antibodies
protect us until
about six months and
then they start waning.
And remember the one
that passes over is
your IgG. So the blood
placental barrier is
strong but it lets some
things through including
medications and
antibodies. So IgG will
be able to cross
through, IgM does not. So
IgG will help with
our immune system and
protect us up until
about six months and then
after six months the
mom's antibodies kind
of start waning and
then if you don't have
antibodies of your
own as a baby then you
start seeing uh problems
with antibody deficiencies
around this age okay
so it kind of fits
um two to six year old
you get less severe
antibody deficiencies
like iga oftentimes
you can go your whole
life without recognizing
that you have iga
deficiency um unless
you get a blood
transfusion or celiac or
something like that that
might prompt testing.
And then some of the
older children, they
can also get secondary
immune deficiencies.
For example, if they
get chemotherapy or have
a really bad EBV
infection, that can also
really cramp down on
their immunofunction.
And then also the
common variable
immune deficiency
also happens
in more older
children, OK,
so this is an important
chart. And then also,
I want you guys to look
at this chart, too,
which is the inheritance
pattern. So in
your question stem,
it'll give you something
that will help you
determine what kind of
inheritance it is. Or it
will ask you, OK, this
is what they were
diagnosed with. What is
the inheritance pattern?
Or a mom has this
disease and she's stinky
about having a child.
What is the chance
that this baby will
have this disease
as well? Right. So
that's how they'll
ask the question.
So remember your X
-linked ones are chronic
granulomatous disease,
Wiscott-Aldrich,
X-linked agamaglomanemia,
X-linked hyper
-IgM, and X-linked
SCID, which is the most
common form of SCID,
which we'll talk about.
Autosomal recessive
will be your ataxia,
leukocyte adhesion defect,
Chiragashi-Hagashi,
Schwann-Diamond
syndrome, which is a bone
marrow defect, and
autosomal recessive.
skin. The only
autosomal dominant one
that we have that's
immunodeficiency
is the hyper-IgE or
the job syndrome.
And then some
sporadic ones are the
genetic DeGeorge
and common variable
immunodeficiencies. Those
are sporadic, right?
So just try to think
about the outliers
and remember the X
-linked because those
will predominantly
affect men, right?
Because they only
have one copy of the X
gene, whereas females
have two copies.
Okay,
and then remember for
adaptive versus innate,
we talked about this
already. For innate,
that's the quick first
responders, and that's
going to be your
phagocytes and complement
system. And the type
of infections you get
are abscesses, soft
tissue infections. With
complement, you get
meningitis, sepsis
specifically from Neisseria
meningitidis um and
then also uh the
abscesses are going to be
Staph aureus uh coagulase
negative serratia
aspergillus all those
for adaptive immune
system those are your
specialized kind of uh
providers and so that
will be your b cells
and t cells so b cells
specifically um cause
will lack of will cause
cytopulmonary infections
and that's because
those antibodies are
so important for that.
And that will mostly
be your strep pneumo,
H-influx, staph,
aureus, pseudomonas,
enterovirus, and giardia.
For T-cells, think
about opportunistic
infections. So it's
really important
to know what your
normal biome is composed
of and then what
constitutes an
opportunistic infection,
right? So candida,
pneumocystis,
mycobacteria, CMV,
those are all
opportunistic infections.
Okay, I hope that helps.
Let's keep going. Okay,
this is a great
chart that I found
in Ruben's pathology,
which is what
we used to use
back in the day.
I thought it was
really helpful, and
I'll kind of reference
this photo on the
left every time I
go through some of
the pathologies
because it helps me
kind of figure out,
okay, it stops working
here, so all this
will be affected.
And I hope it helps you
as well to think about.
Okay, quickly, we'll talk
about the picture
on the right.
Again, it talks
about how, you
know, if T cells
are affected,
you will see a low
lymphocyte count.
You'll see,
oh, sorry, The way
you measure it is
you'll check for
lymphocyte count.
You'll check for
lymphocyte flow cytometry,
specifically the
T-cell markers.
You'll check for T
-cell perforation.
And then the symptoms
you will have are
failure to thrive,
severe viral
infections, which include
HPV infections, so
a lot of warts, and
then recurrent HSV
encephalitis, right?
So HSV is ******.
um and oftentimes they'll
have the meningitis
encephalitis without
having oral lesions
um you can get a life
-threatening EPV infection
which can lead to
something called HLH
which is called um
hemophagocytic lymphocytosis
and uh that is basically
your whole immune
system just goes
haywire and it's a
cytokine storm um I've
seen one patient in the
hospital with this and
they get really sick,
they get multi-organ
failure, they get fevers,
they get pancytopenic,
so it's really
hard, and we have some
immunosuppressants, but
no really, really good
therapies for HLH.
Currently, we have
anakinra, which is your
IL-1 inhibitor, and
that seems to be uh
helping a little bit
okay um now in terms of
fungal infections so
severe candida aspergillus
for those bugs you
can get osteomyelitis
you can get pneumonias
again a weird place
to get them um for
bacterial so more
commonly with b cells
you get the recurrent
cytopulmonary like we
talked about you get the
internal viral
meningitis meningitis you
get bronchiectasis
and then recurring
gastroenteritis um for
uh for phagocytes you'll
get abscesses you get
severe bacterial infections
for wound healing
because remember you
need all those cells
to kind of come there
to help lay down good
foundations to heal
and then periodontal
disease as well um and
then you can check
for uh the neutrophil
count um or the oxidative
burst uh which helps
you determine whether
this is a phagocyte
disorder. For a B cell
disorder, you want
to check for the
immunoglobulin levels,
vaccine titers, because
remember you should
have some sort of a
memory about the vaccine
that you came across
and these should be
IgM and usually IgG
should be responsive of
those old memories.
So IgG is your memory
cell, right? So
lymphocyte flow cytometry,
which also will check
for B cell markers can
also help you if there's
a B cell problem.
For complement, really
Neisseria is your main
one. And again, you're
checking these two
levels of CH50 and
AH50 in the lab work to
see if there's any
deficiencies in the
complement system. You
can also get early onset
lupus and encapsulated
bacterial infections.
Okay, I think that
was pretty much it.
Um, you'll get, uh,
for Neisseria, you
can get Neisseria
meningitis, or you
can disseminate
gonococcal infections as
well. Um, and then,
um, mycobacteria,
uh, is also something
that you can get.
Okay.
All right. So in primary
immune deficiency
disorders, uh,
which is also the
acronym for PID, um,
There are about 550
and still counting
different disorders.
The diagnosis
is tough because
it's really
rare. So to have
immune deficiency
is really rare.
The disease incidence
is low and then your
index suspicion is
usually low because
kids get a lot of
infections, right? So we
say normally for
preschool kids, they
usually get about six
to 10 viral infections
a year and that's
normal, right? Right. So
imagine if, you know,
a parent comes in
like, oh, I don't
know, like they keep
getting infections and
they keep getting sick.
And my first thought
is like, oh, yeah,
you know, the viral
infection is 10 a year,
like preschool
student. That's normal.
But it's helpful to
we'll talk about some
of the alarming things
that will help you
determine, OK, this is
something I actually
need to pay attention
to. um for uh there's
a lot of varied
presentations on immune
deficiencies so um you
won't have one that
presents exactly
like the other um and
they can be complex
phenotypes as well so it
doesn't always fit
the bill um a lot of
this some of the alarming
signs you can see
is infections with
cutaneous lesions failure
to thrive and then
autoimmunity um so
remember that can
present with sort of non
-specific viral illnesses
like fevers up and
down um or really bad
severe allergies um
so uh this is challenging
because again it
requires a lot of
coordination of care as
well these are complex
um usually we um
one of the autoimmunity
diseases that could
clue you off is like
if they get lupus like
early onset lupus
before the age of five
which is really really
rare or even pre
-pubertal is very
uncommon and also getting
like small bowel
enteropathy really early
on like less than six
years of age has about
20% linked to having
some sort of an
underlying autoimmune
or immune dysfunction.
So these are
some things that
can help clue
you in that maybe
there's something
else going on.
Remember the fever
syndromes are a little
bit unique because
they will have fevers
without any infectious
triggers so no uri
symptoms the blood
cultures has been negative
things like that
and usually they'll
get it like once a
month um in about it
takes about two weeks
to recover so it'll be
a very prolonged um
you know duration uh
that's because they
have trouble clearing
the pathogen uh from
the lack of proper
immune system so that
can also clue you in.
So if it's more than
10, the severity
of the symptoms
is very bad.
They're requiring
hospitalization,
really severe
symptoms. They're
requiring prolonged
IV antibiotics.
They don't respond very
well to oral antibiotics.
Then you're,
and they have
a very prolonged
duration.
Then you're
starting to think,
okay, maybe there's
something else
going on that I
need to check on
okay um some of the
remember like the
pathogens that we
talked about the
opportunistic infection
can also clue you
in or if they've been
vaccinated by all of
these that you see here
rotavirus uh varicella
and mmr and they
still get diseases you
can have a little bit
of breakthrough but you
have a much milder
disease but if they have
a full-blown um you
know varicella but
they've already been
vaccinated that's also
an alarming sign that
maybe they're not having
the same immune
response and the memory.
And remember, they're
live attenuated
vaccines, so they're much,
much weaker. So normal
immune systems should
be able to kind of
take care of that
infection and also
develop memory
from it, right?
That's the whole
point of vaccines.
But in these cases, in
these patients, they
won't be able to get
good memory or defeat
the virus. So that can
cause symptom breakthrough.
So that's another
clue. in your lab work
it's possible that
neutropenia slash
lymphocytopenia might be
present you may get some
family history of a
primary immunodeficiency
disorder especially in
the autosomal dominance
that we talked about
or if they have a
history of consiguity
that can also help you
especially if it's an
autosomal recessive
disorder that is showing
up and you're like
how um and that that
might be because the
parents are are um closely
related um so that can
that can also uh show
up as an autosomal
recessive disorder um
and we talked about this
already okay let's
move on um so you you
sort of get a good
history of physical that's
definitely important
getting the cbc with
differential counts you
get some cultures you
get some imaging you
get immuno titers you
can get titers of the
vaccines that we give
so diphtheria and tetanus
you can also check
for pneumococcus and
haemophilus titers and
then the complement
levels like we talked
about if those are all
normal then we talk to
the immunologist and
then we just kind of
consider following these
up however if we get
abnormalities and then
we can kind of go into
each section and be
like what we can do more
things if we suspect
a specific disorder so
for example if you
suspect there's a defect
in b-cells um then
you would check flow
cytometry like we talked
about um and all those
functional b-cell
studies versus a combined
defect you would check
for t-cells b-cells
nk cells um and t-cell
mitogen studies if you
suspect a phagocyte
defect you're going to
check granulomatous
uh chronic disease uh
you're going to check
for those oxidative burst
um things you can also
check for neutrophil
chemotaxis assays il
-12 receptor expression
and then flow cytometry
for the leukocyte
adhesion uh defects so
um and the integrins
like cd11 cd18 and 15
which we'll talk about
so this is sort of i
just want you to have
a like overall kind of map
of what an immunologist
would do in practice
you would do
probably just this much,
if any, and then you'd
send them to an immunologist
if you still were
suspicious of something,
right? So remember,
as a general pediatrician,
you'd probably
just do the upper half
and then send them.
Okay, so this is
what we're going to
cover, and this is not
what we're not going
to cover, because
that's covered in Dr.
Hurst's lecture. So
Dr. Hurst covers IgA
combined variable
immunodifficiency.
He also covers
chronic mycocutaneous
candidiasis,
Chariaki Higashi,
Chronic Ganylonous
Disease,
and Complement
Deficiency.
He might not cover
Complement Deficiency,
but that one is pretty
straightforward, so
I did not cover it
in this lecture. What
is covered in this
lecture is all that we've
talked about and
things that are listed,
okay? So let's get
started. So I'm going
to start first with the
phagocytic disorder,
which is the leukocyte
adhesion deficiency.
There are many types,
but we're going
to talk about just
type 1 because that's
most common and the
easiest to understand.
There's different types,
type 2, type 3 will
affect different parts
of the proteins that
help with chemotaxis.
Okay, so this is an
autosomal recessive
disorder. Okay, it's
a defect in the beta
2 integrin or the
CD18 protein, which is
also referred to as
the leukocyte function
associated antigen
type 1 LFA. And you
can see it right here
in this image um down
here uh you can see
that the cd18 or the
beta 2 integrins um
the uh the neutrophil
or the um granulocyte
uses this to kind
of tumble remember
that nice uh tumbling
and then it it connects
to those proteins
which then connect to
the cell uh the cell
um antigens and then
that goes together
like this and then
allows it to kind of um
diabetes so into the
cell where it is needed
okay so that's the
process so this effect
this will affect
chemotaxis and migration
to the site of need
so as you can imagine
clinically what you'll
see is that you'll have
some sort of abscess
or infection but you
won't see any pus there
because remember the
phagocyte cells cannot
get to the area to
cause the inflammation
and wall off this
area with the bacteria
and then defeat it so
pus is that inflammatory
all that cells
breaking down all the
the bacteria being being
broken right so they're
not able to do that
you'll also have poor
wound healing right
for the same reason
they can't get to
that place to kind
of help for clean it
up and then um for
the fibroblast to
come and kind of fix
things right Right.
So in babies, this
will usually present
with delayed separation
of the umbilical
cord. So here's up
here is the picture
of what the normal
umbilical cord will
do in that normal
process of falling
off. And it usually
takes about 14 days
maximum ish is what
I've seen to fall off,
really falls off
within a week or so.
And this will be
very delayed. So as
in greater than
30 days, I saw
somewhere it can take
up to two months.
separate which is
very very abnormal and
should clue you in that
there might be some
sort of a leukocyte
adhesion deficiency.
Obviously because the
umbilical stump is
on for a very long time
they're at risk for
developing umphillitis
which is infection
of the umbilicus and
also sepsis from that
because if you can
imagine your umbilical
veins and your arteries
were right there
with umbilical cord is
attached right to the
baby so that has a
direct connection to
your venous system and
your arterial system,
which can, if that
gets infected, the
bacteria can travel
into the bloodstream and
cause sepsis, right?
You can also get severe
gingivitis from this
deficiency. In the
labs, you'll actually see
increased neutrophils,
which will show
greater than 20,000.
You'll get abscess
of the neutrophils
at the infection site
itself, which also
will clue you in. And
then the treatment
for this is usually
prophylactic
antibiotics and a
stem cell transplant.
All right, that's that
one. Let's talk
about SCID.
So SCID is a combined T
cell and B cell disorder.
So as I promised earlier,
these are the two
places at which the
pathology will
affect. So there's two
predominant kind of areas
that go wrong in SCID.
So there's over
20 genes that are
involved, but the two
most common ones that we
think about are the
defective IL-2R gamma
chain, which is an
X-linked recessive
inheritance pattern,
which is that one
down here, which prevents
T cell maturation
in the thymus. Okay,
so this is where the
cutoff happens. So
you end up with just
stuck at the lymphoid
progenitor stage.
And then the adenosine
deaminase deficiency,
which is an autosomal
recessive form,
which again, it stops
it actually all the
way up here before the
stem cell even gets
to the lymphoid
progenitor cell. Okay.
This was historically
called the bubble
baby disease or the
bubble boy disease
because of the X
-linked part before we
knew about the other
autosomal recessives
and the other genes
that are involved.
And so you can see
here in the picture
that this baby is
actually inside
the little incubator
looking thing
and the sibling
is trying to give
them a kiss and the
mom is watching.
um so they used to need
reverse uh isolation
in that they needed
actually protection from
the outer world
instead of them being
infectious and spreading
it to other people so
they used to live in
these bubbles before um
we we figured out more
more information about
skid and how to treat
it effectively this
will present very very
early on so first month
to two months of life
it usually presents,
you get loss of both
cell-mediated and humoral
immunity. So if you
can imagine the B
cells and also the T
cells are affected, okay?
You get an absence of
a thymic shadow because
remember the thymus
is where you get
training of those T
cells, right? So if that's
not happening,
the thymus will be
underdeveloped and then
germinal centers are where
your B cells will
mature. So in lymphoid
tissue like lymph
nodes and spleen. So
that's also something
that you want to note.
So because B cells and
T cells are affected,
it's going to be an
abscess of both the
thymic shadow and
germinal centers, okay?
On the newborn screen,
so if you guys remember
what newborn screen
is, so all babies
when they're born,
certain states have
different newborn screens.
So they compose about
50 different diseases
uh it can be something
like pku hypothyroidism
sickle cells
cf um cystic fibrosis
sorry um congenital
adrenal uh hyperplasia
so all these things
are tested in the
newborn screen depending
on what state you're in
and one of the things
that um is on the
newborn screen is
something called the
trex so that stands for t
-cell receptor excision
circles, which are
basically circular
DNA that's formed in T
cells in the thymus. So
this will be very low
or undetectable. And
if that's the case,
that will show up on
the newborn screen as
undetectable trex,
okay? And that might
clue you in that there's
something going on.
The IL-2R gamma chain
mutation affects about
30% of skin cases,
which is deemed the
most common. And that
one you'll have a low
you'll have low T cells
but B cells will be
present but they really
cannot function very
well so remember you
need the you need
the the T cells to
talk to the B cells to
kind of get all that
good downstream effects
so in the x-link you
will have no T cells
and less NK cells but
the B cells will be
present. Again, non
-functional though, okay?
Because they need that
signaling from
the T cell.
The ADA, which is the
adenosine deaminase
deficiency one, which
is up here, all of the
lines will be down.
And K cells, T cells,
and B cells, which makes
sense, right? Because
it's upstream to the
X-ling part or the
defective IL-2R part. So
if it's upstream, it's
actually affecting
before it even gets to
the lymphoid progenital
cell. So the B cells
will also be affected,
okay? So T cell, B
cell, and NK cells
will all be down, okay?
What the ADA does
is basically,
it's a, sorry, not ADA,
ADD, sorry. So that
is basically, it
breaks down
deoxyadenosine, which
is generated when
the DNA is broken.
When this cannot be
broken down, it builds
up in the cell and
is very harmful.
So this causes cell
death in the immune
cells. So like
lymphocytes, T cells, NK
cells, B cells, things
like that. Okay.
Okay. So these
patients will present
with recurrent bacterial,
fungal, viral,
protozoal infections.
They will also
present with failure
to thrive,
chronic diarrhea,
and thrush,
okay?
Again, think about
B cells, C cells,
and how this affects
this part, okay?
Before treatment,
they used to
have a lifespan
of about two
years maximum,
but often the
recurrent infections
and the severity
of the infections
would kill these kids.
um if this was
diagnosed early they
had a better long
time survival um and
yeah
all right let's talk
a little bit about
treatments i think this
is so fascinating so uh
for treatment temporarily
you can do prophylaxis
antibiotics you can
do antivirals you
can do antifungals
right to prevent them
from getting pervasive
uh infections you can
also do because Because
the B cells are affected
in specifically the
ADA deficiency, you
can do immunoglobulin
replacement therapies.
So, giving them
immunoglobulins like IgG,
IVIG, for example,
IgM, you can give
them immunoglobulins.
You also want to
avoid doing any live
attenuator vaccines
on these patients.
Because, again,
they do not have the
immunofunction to
develop immunity and that
will just end up
harming them. Okay.
So the new treatments
are actually really
exciting. So prior to
this, they used to do
stem cell transplants
for all these patients.
And that involved,
you know, doing
chemotherapy to kind
of obliterate any
bone marrow, any
stem cells that could
have been into
lymphoid cells that
may prevent the
graft from sticking.
and to make space
for the new cells.
So usually
involves some sort
of conditioning
with chemo drugs.
And usually you
pick a donor that's
going to be a fully
matched sibling
donor. So that's
the best match that
you can get is a
full sibling donor.
And they'll match
the HLA parts
to make sure that
they're good.
They'll be a good match
for each other. Okay.
um if the immune
system is really really
down and they've had
some severe infections
they're not going
to do a bone marrow
transplant and you know
give them chemo if the
baby's less than two
months they're also
too young to receive
chemo and do a transplant
so um those are some
things to kind of
keep in mind that there
there is good reasoning
to do the bone marrow
transplant because
it's curative but also
there's some things
that prevent the
kid from getting the
bone marrow um uh the
transplant okay which
is the same thing as
hematopoietic okay um
if they for example
don't have a fully
matched sibling donor
um then you also have
to start thinking about
other options that
you may have because
if if the HLA don't
match then there's a
high risk for rejection
okay um all right so
specifically the other
therapies that we have
is um for ada deficient
patients there's
actually an enzyme
replacement therapy um
which is really cool
because you just kind
of give them the enzyme
and that breaks down
some of that that
deoxy adenosine which
we talked about is that
harmful substance
that builds up and i'm
sorry i didn't mention
but in in ada you'll
have an increased urine
deoxyadenosine which
is that that uh the
harmful material that
builds up that we talked
about um okay sorry
so um we talked about
this yes so it will
help break it down
and therefore helps
patients um they require
weekly im injections
so usually it's
temporary but it can help
them kind of increase
their immunity for a
little while um before
they're ready for a
stem cell transplant
or or gene therapy okay
so this is the really
cool part so if you
don't have a match or
the there's some trouble
uh with the actual
stem cell transplant
you can also do gene
therapy and that
eliminates some of the
rejection and the incomplete
grafting that we see
we have previously
seen in some stem
cell transplants um
unfortunately this is
not fda approved yet
there's a lot of clinical
trials going on for
this, but it's super,
super cool. So St. Jude
does this. They've
done it successfully.
So what they'll do is
they'll extract bone
marrow stem cells
from the patient. They
will have a lentiviral
vector, which they will
implant basically
a viral vector and
implant the DNA that we
want into it and that
viral vector would
will then be placed in
the same area as the
cells the stem cells so
when the virus then
injects the cell with
new DNA all the cells
the stem cells that
you gave that you
retrieved from the patient
will all have that DNA
that you want right
so we preserve those
and then you give
them a little bit of
conditioning with one of
the chemotherapy drugs
and that will make
room for the stem cells
in the transplant.
So then you would take
the cells that you
preserve, the ones
with the DNA that you
want and put them
back into the patient.
So because it's
their own stem cells,
you don't have to
worry about matching,
right? Or rejection
because it's their own
cells and you're
eliminating usually a
chance of rejection
of their own cells if
they will have any,
which is very rare with
some conditioning
of the chemotherapy.
So this is really,
really cool, cool things,
cool stuff. So you
basically take out their
own cells, you modify
them the way you want
with some sort of a
vector, and they use
lentiviral instead of
a retroviral because
they found that the
retroviral will actually
put them at more risk
for developing cancers
in the future. So
lentiviral is doing
a great job of putting
the DNA in and not
causing that the dna
to abnormally replicate
um so this is a very
promising uh promising
new therapy for
specifically the x
-legged skin um really
cool really cool stuff
all right um let's go
into the t-cell disorder
so thymic aplasia
which is also one of
the syndromes that's
associated with that
which you'll commonly
see in your question
steps is going to be
de george syndrome um
i'm sure you guys have
heard of before it's
the 22q 11.2 micro
deletion and it's basically
a failure to develop
the third and fourth
pharyngeal arch uh
pharyngeal pouch sorry
um dr solunius will
be so disappointed in
me um and basically
the concept is you're
going to have an absent
uh thymus you will
have an absent
parathyroid hormone uh
parathyroid gland. So,
what you're going to find
is immune dysfunction
and hypocalcemia,
okay, because of those
specific things. You
can also get craniofacial
abnormalities like
microognathia, which
is a small jaw. You
can have retroognathia,
which is a slightly
deviated jaw to the
back, underdeveloped.
You can get a cleft
palate, cleft lip. You
can also get cardiac
abnormalities, right?
So tetralogy of the
low, truncus arteriosus,
those are all things
that you can find
with DeGeorge syndrome
or that problem with
that third and fourth
pharyngeal pouch forming.
Okay, go back to
embryology, it'll make
sense why all these
things are affected.
Okay, and the
problem here is that
because there's
no thymus, these
T cells don't get
educated, right?
There's a decreased
number in the periphery
um but they don't
get educated so they
cannot get they
cannot fight the the
infections as they should
so um on chest x-ray
you'll find an absent
thymic shadow okay
so here you can see it
um here on the right
side you see this
big kind of excuse me
opacity so most people
think that's a pneumonia
but actually this is
the thymic shadow in a
newborn and sometimes
it can show up as this
patient's a little
rotated but sometimes
you can see a large
mediastinal like opacity
which you'll be like
oh my god um but it's
actually the thymus okay
so um babies have huge
thymuses and they
regress over time as we
become into adulthood
they get very very
small um because all of
the education is mostly
done for the t-cells
okay um in the lymph
nodes the paracortex
will be underdeveloped.
Remember that the
B cells and the NK
cells will be fine
because they don't
get educated in the
thymus, right? The
T cells get educated
in the thymus.
Okay, and they go into
the periphery after
they've been to the
thymus, right? So they'll
be stuck in this kind
of immature stage
and won't be able to
go into that mature
stage. So you will have
a decrease in peripheral
um sorry peripheral
uh numbers okay and
that's why you have
that decrease the
underdevelopment of
the paracortex for the
treatment of de george
syndrome uh or actually
more of a thymic aplasia
in the immune part
is you're going to do
prophylactic antivirals
antibiotics and
antifungals you can also
do this is also really
cool you can do a
one-time thymic tissue
transplant which the
FDA approved in 2021
really really cool um
and it's called re
-thymic it's FDA approved
um like I said and
you basically take
thymic tissue from babies
less than nine months
who are undergoing
heart surgery um and
then you transplant
that into um into the
donor that you need um
and you actually don't
even have to worry
about HLA typing um
which is really cool
because it's not a stem
cell it's just a part
of the thymus that
you're you're putting
implanting um so very
very cool stuff and
they'll do it inside the
on the the inner part
of the thigh and it
still provides the same
functionality as as
the thymus would in
the mediastinum really
cool okay sorry all
right so let's talk
about the b cell disorder
the bruton x-linked
agammaglubinemia. So the
defect is right here.
So you get a defect
in the tyrosine kinase
which is encoded by the
BTK gene which basically
makes light chains
in antibodies. So you
don't get maturation
of the B cells in the
peripheral blood and
they get trapped in the
bone marrow. So as you
can imagine if it cuts
off here it can't really
go up to peripheral
sites and the B cells
will be mostly trapped
in the bone marrow
so you get very very
low or absent b cells
in the peripheral blood
um you get absent lymph
nodes you get absolute
tonsils um the
primary follicles and
germinal centers and lymph
nodes are also absent
specifically right
because those are the
peripheral sites in
which the b cells will um
will mature um so one
of the the markers that
we have for b cells
is CD19, right, 1920.
So those will be
very, very low. That's
another marker of
saying basically that B
cells are low. And this
is, you can, for flow
cytometry, that can
show you what CD
present, the CD markers
are present. And that
can, that can help
you determine whether
it's a T cell or or a
B cell defect, right?
Remember the T cell
markers are
CD3, CD4, CD8.
The B cell ones are
mostly 19, 20, 20.
Okay,
this is a X-linked
disorder, obviously,
as it has it in
its name, so it
primarily affects
boys, and you can
remember it by
Bruton, boys, and BTK.
Sorry, that's the
gene. Okay, so
you're going to
get all these
immunoglobulins will
all be decreased,
right? And remember,
this presents after
six months, because
thanks to mom, we have
antibodies for at
least six months before
they start waiting
so these patients
will be at risk for
recurrent bacterial
infections including
h flu strep pneumo um
so otitis media very
common sinusitis very
common pneumonia is
very common you can
also get gi bugs so
interviral infections
you cannot give these
patients live vaccines
much like all the other
immunodeficiencies
and the treatment
is a lifelong
immunoglobulin replacement
therapy. So IVIG,
IgM, IgA, IgE kind of
replacements, okay?
Pretty straightforward.
Then we go to another
B-cell disorder, which
is hyper-IgM syndrome.
So basically what
happens is you have
a defective CD40L,
which is the ligand
that helps convert, um,
the class switching,
uh, between IgM
to IgG to IgA to
IgE. Um, so you get
very, uh, you get
elevated IgM, um,
or normal IgM and
all the other cell,
uh, the other
immunoglobulins will be low.
So IgG will be low,
IgA will be low, IgE
will be low. So you
also get a failure to
make germinal centers
because that's a main
area where the class
switching will happen.
This is also an X-linked
recessive disease.
Remember the difference
between hyper
IgM and X-linked is
X-linked will be all
low. IgM will also be
low versus in the hyper
IgM, only IgM will
be normal or high.
Everything else will be
low. Okay. It's further
down in the list in
the kind of order.
You get severe pyogenic
infections early
in life. So opportunistic
infections with
pneumocystis,
cryptosporidium, and CMV
are very commonly seen.
And remember, there's
an X-linked recessive
disorder, same
thing as Bruton and
no-affect voice. Okay,
all right, moving on.
Another B-cell
disorder is called
Jobe syndrome or
hyper-IGE syndrome.
This is an autosomal
dominant. So again,
this is different than
all the other ones.
So remember that,
autosomal dominant.
There is a deficiency
in the TH17 cells
because there's a STAT3
mutation on chromosome
17, which encodes for
basically developmental
things for TH17 cells.
So what you're not
getting is all of
this, TH17, which is
really important in helping
um prevent autoimmunity
and break uh and uh
tumor uh formation
so you get less of the
th 17 and the way i
like to think about
it is if you make less
less of the 17 you're
going to make more for
the th2 um and therefore
have some of those
symptoms that we
see for il-4 il-5 so
allergies uh like
dermatologic eczema picture.
Your IgE will be
increased. Your
eosinophils will
be increased.
For the face, you'll
get coarse face
seeds, which is part
of the genetic part.
And then this is
showing severe eczema
that you can see in
the upper picture
over here in a
darker skinned baby.
You will also see
retained baby teeth.
So they'll have often
two rows of teeth,
um which sort of
you can see here but
it's hard to tell um
the x-ray you'll be
able to see two sets
of teeth and again
you'll see cold staph
abscesses because
they're not able to
kind of get to that
area okay um and you
can also see fractures
from minor trauma
okay so that's job
all right let's go
into other so we have
wiscot aldrich syndrome
which is really
interesting um It is
X-linked recessive,
so remember affecting
boys, which is
a picture of this
little boy right here.
You get a mutation
in the WAAS
gene, which affects
not only B cells
and T cells, but
also platelets.
So you're basically
unable to reorganize the
acting cytoskeleton,
and that's super
important in presenting
the antigen. Remember,
the B cells will present
the antigen to the
T cells, and then that
will activate b cells
and t cells right
um so you have that
problem and then the
platelets also use actin
cytoskeletons to kind
of move around and and
help with um with
help with uh primary
hemostasis so uh you get
uh recurrent pyogenic
infections so sinus
ear pneumonia like you
see in all the other
ones the the things
that are different in
this one is you'll see
thrombocytopenia okay
uh you can see you will
see smaller fewer
platelets and bleeding
is the most common
cause of death actually.
You'll find eczema as
well. So skin eczema.
So this is what you're
seeing over here
in graph B or picture
B is some eczema
here. In A you see a
little petechiae on
the baby boy's face and
you can tell because
these won't be able
to be blanchable and
he has a little bit
of bruising as well
as some ecchymosis under
the right periorbital
area, which could
be a sign of
bleeding. Okay. So these
will not be blanchable.
So when you press
your thumb onto it,
it will not make it
go away. Okay. Okay.
You have increased
risk for autoimmunity
and malignancy in this
disorder, and you get
decreased to normal
IgG, IgM levels, but
you get increase of
IgG and IgA levels.
You're going
to avoid live
attenuated vaccines
in this one.
For treatment,
antibiotic
prophylaxis and IV
immunoglobulins are the
temporary treatment.
And now, and then
previously, we thought
that the bone marrow
transplant was the only
way to treat these
patients um after
conditioning but in f uh
in 2025 so literally last
year fda approved a
gene therapy um via
the viral vector that
we talked about uh that
starts making then
the wasp gene and the
protein which is really
really cool which
incorporates wasp gene
which then enables the
cell to make their
own protein which is
really cool um the rate
of severe infections
decreased by 93
percent in six to eight
months after they received
the treatment, the
gene therapy. It also
reduced the incidence
of bleeding, moderate
to severe bleeding
events by 60 percent
in the first 12 months.
We very often, very
less commonly will
give these patients
platelet infusions
because it's going to be
temporary, it's
not going to work.
But you can do that
if they have severe
bleeding going on and
you want to help them.
If they have severe
bleeding and they need
frequent platelet
infusions, the other
thing we can also do is
take out their spleen,
so a splenectomy,
because remember the
spleen collects all
your damaged cells, so
they will also collect
platelets as well.
So that's one
thing that you can
do. And sometimes
that's been shown
to prevent platelet
destruction.
Okay.
And then the last
one we're going to
talk about is ataxia,
telectasia. Oh,
my God, I can never
say this word.
Telectasia.
So ATs. So this is
also kind of cool.
So it's a defect in
the ATM gene, which is
located on chromosome
11. And what happens
is you get failure to
stop the progression
or the checkpoints
of the cell cycle.
So a defective ATM
prevents P53, which,
remember, is really
important for
apoptosis. It's a
checkpoint to make
sure everything is
copying correctly.
And so what you get
is you're more prone
to mutations. and
these patients will
actually be at increased
risk for lymphoma
and leukemia
because of that
uncontrolled, you know,
cell division because
now you're eliminating
the checkpoints.
Okay, so they can't
detect DNA damage, so
they'll just keep
replicating and replicating
and eventually that
will cause cancer.
The onset of these
symptoms are usually
two to five years old
um and they they really
decline fast because
this also affects
the cerebellum so
they get cerebellar
defects like all the
ones that we talked about
in dpr so ataxia they
can't walk straight
they're kind of
wobbling over dysarthria
so they can't speak
straight um dysmetria
which is when you do
the finger to nose
and you end up going
like this when you're
when you tell them
to touch your finger
they're like like this
right or they miss
they miss your finger
that's dysmetria
with more severe decline
you can think you
can have things like
dysphagia as well where
they won't be able
to swallow okay and
that might not these signs
might not be noticeable
until like four to
eight years of age
um spider these are
classified by um spider
angiomas so talactasias
so that's what
you're seeing here which
is the picture right
these abnormal kind of
capillary areas. And
you can have ocular
ones and cutaneous ones
as well. There is
extreme sensitivity to
radiation. So when they
get x-rays, you have
to be very careful
because remember x-rays
cause DNA breaks and
this patient already
has defective recognition
of those breaks.
About two-thirds
of these patients
will actually be
IgA deficient,
which is actually
really interesting.
We talked about the
risk of lymphoma,
leukemia. They'll have
increased IgG and IgE,
but the T-cell will be
variable in terms of
how depressed the T
-cell function will be.
Also,
alpha-fetoprotein
will also be
increased. I don't
exactly know why.
Lymphopenia and the
cellular cerebellar
atrophy can lead to a
lot of uncoordinated
movements, like we talked
about the ataxia and
frequent falls um and
the treatment for this
is usually immunoglobulin
therapy and prophylactic
antibiotics for the
immune part of it
okay let's go back
to our question so um
all the things that we
talked about two month
old *** pneumonia
multiple episodes
thrush requiring
prolonged antifungal has
dermatitis has otitis
media failure to grow um
oh i forgot to mention
oh i forgot to to
highlight this the
watery diarrhea every
day is also i don't
know if i include that
in the beginning but
anyway the watery
diarrhea would also cool
you off absent thymic
shadow decrease all
cell lines and decrease
immunoglobulins okay
so you know it's
going to be a very early
present uh presenting
pathology right
because this patient
is only two months they
have an absent thymic
shadow which tells
you t cells are
decreased but they already
tell you that because
they did a flow
cytometry right Right.
So you have all the
cell lines that are
affected and immunoglobulins
are also affected,
which is a downstream
part of the decreased
B cells part. Right.
So this is a so the
question after asked
you the mechanism will
also ask you, OK,
what would the newborn
screening show? And this
disease, this question
stem is asking about
SCID. right and remember
there's two flavors
there's the x-linked
IL-2R mutation or the
autosomal recessive
ADA deficient one this
one's a male um which
could tell you it's x
-linked or or it could
be red herring so just
keep that in mind um
all three cell levels
are down which which
goes along more with
the ADA deficiency
right um and remember
you'll get the chronic
diarrhea failure to thrive
you get the recurrent
infections, and the
newborn screen would
show very very low
T-cells or the Trex,
which is the DNA that's
in the T-cells, okay?
So this is a skin
presentation, most likely
the ADA one versus the
X-linked IL-2R one,
because if it was the
IL-2R one, the B-cells
would be okay, the T
cells and NK cells would
be severely low. Okay,
so that helps you.
Okay.
Yeah, this is
exactly sort
of what we talked about.
Oh, this is
important. I wanted to
show you guys where
the ADA works.
So this is the
adenosine deaminase, and
this is deficient in
SCID, so you don't
get this breakdown of
the deoxyadenosine,
which is what you
get buildup of.
So this was helpful
to me, and this
is important for
recycling the DNA
components, right,
the ribosome 5
-phosphate, which is
that triangular part
that forms the
nucleosides, okay?
This is another chart
that kind of helps
summarize things.
We already talked
about all of it, but
if that helps you
understand it better,
that's also good.
All right, let's do
another question for
retention. this is a
five-year-old brought to
the ed for three days
of severe left ear pain
associated with fever
you check his medical
history and note that
he's had four episodes
of acute otitis media
this year despite
having ear tubes placed
by ent when he is three
years old when
you complete a med
reconciliation medication
reconciliation you note
that he's completed a
five he just completed
a five-day course of
sulfamethasone and
trimethoprim so you guys
will tell me what that
that um antibiotic does
uh for a skin infection
that was superimposed
on his eczematous
lesions as per mother
it has not improved
though okay you suspect
there's more than just
another otitis media
going on um and you
get some basic blood
work so what do you start
with okay so i sort
of gave you the answer
for this one but again
i wanted you to kind
of think about it
before uh beforehand um
you would start with
just a cbc right a cbc
with differential which
will have the breakdown
of what cells they
see um you'll get some
igg levels you get um
immunoglobulin levels
uh you can get a plus
uh chest x-ray plus
or minus um you can
get a blood culture
depending on how sick
the kid looks um and of
course you will get an
immunology console in
the ed right um but i
wouldn't be like oh yeah
this patient just has
no taste media let
me just give them
amoxicillin and send them
home because it looks
like they're there they
could be sicker than
that okay um they you
get some uh you get
cbc back and it shows a
platelets of 50k okay
normal is 150 to 400
um the igm shows um
shows it's 20 which is
decreased normal should
be 40 to 230 um and
the iga is 500 which is
a little bit elevated
so normal is 70 to 400
and the serum igg is
900 which is actually
normal. So what's
pertinent here is we
see thrombocytopenia and
a decreased IgM, but
IgA and IgG are fine, if
not a little bit
elevated for the IgA. So
it's asking what is
the most likely defect
associated with this
immunodeficiency? Okay,
so we've got some skin
infections. We've got
two ear infections.
He's an older-ish kid.
You see that they
have examinous
lesions as well.
So it has eczema,
thrombocytopenia,
and it's a male. It's
telling you it's
a male. Okay, so I
want you guys to
think about that.
Okay, so these are the
options that you'll
have. So you have a
micro deletion of long
arm of chromosome
22, which is A, B,
mutation of the adenosine
deaminase gene on
chromosome 20, mutation
of the Bruton tyrosine
kinase gene on
chromosome X, or mutation
of the single
transducer and activator
of transcription 3
on chromosome 17, and
then the last one,
mutation of the Wiscott
-Eldrich syndrome gene
on the X chromosome,
okay? So you have to
know a couple things.
You have to know
which, hopefully these
are paired correctly,
but sometimes they're
not, and that's an easy
giveaway that that's
not the inheritance
pattern, and that's
not going to be the
right answer, right?
And then you kind
of have to go from
there, based off of
which answer choice
you think it's going
to be most likely.
So, let me think
about it for a second.
What do you think
an answer would be?
Here's the other
slide for reference.
And then I went through
and kind of another
testing strategy is
going through the
question answers and to
see what disease they
were kind of asking for,
right? Because these
things will show up
again in a different
way, in a different
question stem. So it's
really important to
kind of be like, okay,
go through each one
and say, okay, this is
what this disease is,
this is what this disease
is. So that's exactly
what I did. So for
A, chromosome 22,
remember that's DeGeorge
syndrome, the
microdeletion. For answer
choice B, the adenosine
deaminase, the SCID.
C is going to
be your Bruton
X-linked, a
gamma globinemia.
D is going to
be the STAT3
mutation, which
is Job syndrome.
And E, which is
your Wiscot-Alder
syndrome. Okay, so
again, it helps.
And then these are
the things that
I highlighted.
Remember, five years
old, the acute
otitis media
infections, despite
having ear tubes,
exemptions, lesions,
not improving,
platelets are
low, IgM is low.
So this answer
was E, which
is Wiskott
-Aldridge syndrome.
Okay, and this is the
explanation of it.
You guys can read this
on your own time. And
then these are the
sources. um I found that
uh the med lectures
made easy on YouTube
has a good primary immune
deficiency disorder
YouTube video is
really helpful it might
serve like a good
supplement to this um
or even the osmosis
lectures on on immune
deficiencies are really
good um if you don't
have osmosis you can
google most of them
uh and so hopefully
you're able to get more
of a I know these are
difficult I know it's
hard to memorize but
the more you kind
of review them the
better you'll get at it
and remember the basic
overall concepts uh
to kind of help you
hone in that this is
even a new deficiency
even in the first place
right so um so that's
what i want you guys
to get out of it so
thank you for listening
and watching this
lecture um please give
us feedback so i can
help improve for next
time um this is me
when i was i don't know
how old i was but
um you know i love
flowers so that's a
picture of me so um please
fill out the feedback
form please please
please is really helpful
for all of us and
for your education too
so we're not giving
you boring lectures
okay thank you so much